is from a couple years ago Norm McDonald
one of our greatest modern comedians who
unfortunately passed away about two
years ago I just loved Norm met him a
couple times here he is a couple years
ago talking about this new woke term
cisgender and the point guys again you
just have to be able to laugh at their
nonsense
you know that that you are a CIS male
have you ever heard of that term
CIS male
c-y-s-m-a-l-a so what it means is that
you are a man you're born a man well as
far as you know as far as I know and you
identify yourself as a man yes that's a
CIS male now I don't understand where is
that is this a new phrase yes it's a way
of marginalizing a normal person
another person's a Tran so you're equal
she she's a man that thinks she's a
woman you're a man that thinks you're a
man
it's completely everyone's it's all
fluid yes everyone is is
self-identifying
guys the point is it's all ridiculous we
can use their language we can try to
just respond to them or what do I always
say we can build no thing new things we
can fight back effectively we can
separate from them we can elect better
politicians and adjust at the end of the
day it's all
us
[Music]